okay so I'm Jim Liebman I'm Columbia Law
professor believe it or not I run a
Center at Columbia and what we do is we
bring upper level graduate students from
all over the country to spend a semester
with us learning how to be improvement
engineers in whatever career they choose
to go into but we really hope they will
go into and try to get them into the
public sector especially focused on
public education and what we do is to
teach them how to do measurement for
improvement and one of the ways we teach
them is to get them to work with us in
interdisciplinary teams doing
performance measurement projects all
over the country and in Brazil so if you
think you might need our help let me
know so what we try to teach them and we
teach them this in 70 hours of
instruction which is going to be
compressed into 15 minutes here so I've
given you this PowerPoint and my power
slide notes so you can follow up on a
lot of the detail here that I won't be
able to discuss with you but basically
the idea here is in a sense to not have
to have the evaluator because you build
into everything you're doing every day
the opportunity as Jeanne said to learn
from failure and so we call that
evolutionary learning building into
everyday activity measures of your
success and so a little story very
quickly the United States in the early
1950s realized that if it could build a
nuclear submarine one that did not have
an internal combustion engine in it it
could be under the water for a long long
period of time and essentially change
the strategic balance across the world
but there was a problem which was it's
very dangerous to put a nuclear reactor
inside of a sub and a lot of sailors in
there with it and there was no baseline
nobody knew how to do this nobody nobody
had ever done it before and it wasn't
the kind of thing that you'd say well
let's go do it put the men in the
submarine ship them out there and so yet
a few accidents will learn from that so
Admiral
Hyman rickover had to figure out how you
could build something like this which to
this day in the nuclear Navy in the
United States there's never been a
reactor accident there have been
Russians and the Japanese Phelps but not
ours and the way he figured out to do
this is basically this evolutionary
learning process and that was to set
expectations really clearly for exactly
what you were going to do with every
little bit of the design and engineering
and building process so big issue Wells
what were they going to weld the casing
for that nuclear reactor with we're
gonna use silver they were going to use
cadmium so what they did was they said
for every single weld we are going to
predict exactly how much pressure that
weld can hold and then they would do the
weld they would try the pressure on it
and they would compare the outcomes and
if the outcome was different in any way
if the outcome was better than they
thought or worse than they thought that
was an error they did not have full
information and so they then did a
problem-solving process to figure out
where they'd made their mistake in the
expectations and then they come up with
a new expectation and they would do
another weld and they would try those
out until they got every one of their
welds coming out exactly as they
predicted so that is evolutionary
learning or learning from mistakes
learning from error okay so by the way
Toyota beat the American automakers and
the European ones using the same method
you'll have some materials like that in
your conference so they're really three
steps here which are be clear about what
you expect to do and to happen in order
for you to succeed measure whether your
actual actions and results match your
expectations if you find deviations
between expectations and results that's
great you've got something you can learn
from and so and and the big thing to do
I'm gonna give you lots of ideas here
don't take them all the basic idea is
will they help you learn and improve if
you don't think so skip them or
customize them too
what you might want to do so how do you
get clear about what you expect to do
and happen in order to succeed so what
we recommend is a very simple idea come
up with a theory of action remember that
first word it's a theory it's a
hypothesis it's just what you think
you're gonna do in order to get where
you want to go but it's not anything
more than that and the only way to test
it is by putting it into effect and then
you test your theory so a theory of
action typically works in very simple if
then as a result statements if we do
this we expect these things to follow
and after that we expect our impact or
our desired
aim to follow so here is an example of a
theory of action that we came up with
for and school system imaginary school
system named appleson and they're trying
to create a program to help middle
school maths students be ready for what
they need to accomplish when they get to
high school so here's the theory of
action for that and I'm not going to
read it but a theory of action then is a
first step but it's not enough it's way
too high level so what we have come up
with is this idea of an operationalized
theory of action which breaks down your
theory of action what you expect to do
into a set of inputs that will support
actions which will lead to outcomes
outcomes are what you expect to see in
changed beliefs changed behaviors
changed intermediate results that will
then lead to your impact so you
translate your if your if statements
into those inputs and actions you
translate your then into outcomes and
your as a result into impact and then
what you do so here for the Appleton
example is the operationalize theory of
action so some inputs etc all there you
can take a look at that okay so now you
have made clear to yourself what you
expect to do and
to happen and that's really important
you always think well we know what we
want to do but if you try to lay it out
with some clarity you'll learn a lot
about it and you'll find out you really
didn't know everything you thought you
did so it's helpful it's a strategic
tool even if you're not measuring okay
now what you want to do is measure
whether you get the results that you
thought you were going to get and it's
not just the results did you put the
inputs in place to do take the actions
and when I say take the actions did you
do the things you wanted to do at the
level of quality that you wanted to do
them do they have those intermediate
results did people start changing their
mindsets changing their behaviors and
things like that
and so that's why we're going to measure
there are lots of different kinds of
measures there process measures those
are the things that measure whether you
did what you thought you were going to
do and you did it at the level of
quality that you wanted to do they're
leading indicators they're really
important if they're going wrong forget
about the outcomes you don't have to
wait for the outcomes you're likely not
to get to the outcomes because you're
not doing what you expected to do or not
doing it very well so this gives you a
lot of early warning about what to do
then you can measure your outcomes these
are those intermediate things that you
expect to see happening changes in
beliefs and behaviors then there are
these other kinds of measures that are
talked about there so here is an
alignment of the Appleton operationalize
theory of action with some indicators of
each of crucial things that they were
going to do as inputs as actions and we
come up with an indicator of what will
tell us that we did what we thought we
were going to do at the level of quality
we thought we wanted and getting these
outcomes that we thought we would get
and then an indicator for the ultimate
impact that you are seeking and so lots
of questions to ask about measures are
you going to do process
or both measures quality and don't
forget about quality we often want to
measure how many people came to the
training but we don't measure whether
they learned anything so that's an
important thing to do I'll talk a little
bit more about tools we think it's
really important for you to set a target
for each one of those indicators where
you expect to get as a number or as some
kind of a quality that you can measure
so that you have that expectation set
that you can compare to your actual
results and if you find a discrepancy
you can learn from all of that so here
are a bunch of kinds of tools surveys
in-person protocols administrative
records you collect all sorts of data
just because you write down the names of
everybody who says they're going to come
or things like that that's
administrative data that's there that
you collect in any event standardized
assessments and rubrics are another
which is a rubric isn't something you
use when you're doing an observation and
so and we you in setting your targets
something you want to do is benchmark so
you want to benchmark against your own
past performance or against the
performance of somebody else is doing
something similar and these are
questions that you want to ask you don't
have to have a measure for every input
action etc pick the ones that are
important pick the ones that you think
you can measure best and these are some
of the questions you can ask about
whether to come up with a measure and
what kind of measure and all of that so
ability to gauge quality and quantity
feasibility it's best to use data that
you already have even if it's kind of a
proxy for what you're looking for will
it reveal variation it's important and
you want to be able to embed it in your
everyday operations so you're doing your
own evaluation you don't need that
evaluator to spend all that money on and
then
there is this process of analyzing
deviations between what you thought we
were gonna do or what's gonna happen and
what actually happens how much time do I
have four minutes okay so I'm just gonna
go through this really quickly the
problem-solving process actually is the
most important one sometimes we get
really excited about measuring and we've
got all those measurements and then it
looks like things aren't going as well
as we thought and that's where we
stopped no that's actually the most
important point is to come and this is
it this is a problem-solving method that
we have come up with others use some
very similar to this so you've got to
organize your effort get your team
together that you want to use to figure
out what's going wrong and the comments
that that earlier talk about bringing
people together who are actually the
consumers of it they're really good
people to have on the teams analyze the
problem to do that you want to figure
out cause you're not going to do this
deductively you're gonna come up with
some practical methods for guessing
about what we're learning about causes
then you want to refine your problem and
your aim this is actually really
important in thinking about that
ultimate impact we have some tools for
how you come up with what your ultimate
aim is then you develop a strategy for
solving the problem and the really most
important thing to do is to come up with
quick ways to test your strategy and by
quick I mean an hour or two days or at
most a couple of weeks where you try to
pick some part of that strategy out run
it in front of some kind of an audience
and then see if it is working because
why waste the time coming up with a big
solution implementing it across all your
scale if it's not a great idea and then
the rest that we have I have here here's
some thinking about how you come
with that problem statement here's how
you come up with I'm thinking about what
your aim is smart goals just like you've
heard before
and this is some problem add some causal
analysis the five why's for coming up
with possible causes there fishbone
exercises for cop coming up with
possible causes here's one filled out
for an example that's traced through all
of these things that I've just mentioned
and then when you want to come up with a
solution you say okay what's our aim
what kinds of big changes do we think we
need what actions would we have to take
to make those changes occur and this is
a driver diagram of that sort filled out
for the example that I've been writing
through here and then there's this test
cycle that you can go through so the
main thing here is the one thing I said
we also talked about prototyping here
which is just do things that are
practical and you think will help you
improve learn and improve sorry I had to
go through it so quickly but there is a
process to this there are a number of
organizations that help others as we do
to build this into your everyday
activities
that was the best question possible
[Applause]
you